not to be dramatic
but I think I might have just had the best
weekend of my entire life
and I didn't achieve anything
no cleaning
no renovation
no jobs no work
I was just present in the moment
and god it was good
I kicked off the weekend by having a one on one
mini golf date with my middle child
my boy Malachi
and normally I never show my kids on TikTok okay
but I really wanna be able to relive this weekend over and over
also I think it's important for you to know
that sometimes I do other things
and I don't just spend all of my time cleaning
one thing that you might not know about me
is once upon a time
I used to be young and quite fun
one of my first jobs
like 16 years ago
was at a dance music radio station
and that really just fostered this love of gigs
and going out and listening to live music
and talking shit obviously
and you probably already know
but I became a mother at 20
so for a big chunk of the last 12 years
I haven't really gone out a whole lot
and one thing that my husband
and I decided when we moved back to Auckland last year
was that we wanted to spend our money on making memories
and sharing experiences together
so when my sister in law and her partner
invited us to come to Synthony
to celebrate
her birthday
we thought hell yeah
that sounds great
our friend Clint Roberts was an amazing MC
and we saw Tiki Taane
Fat Freddy's Drop, Synthony and Rudimental I won't lie
I was a little bit overwhelmed by the sheer
number of people that were there
and they said that they were expecting 35,000
I didn't believe them but yep
there was 35,000 there
and we called it a night quite early
cause I didn't wanna feel tired the next day
this spider lives my car by the way
and I can't catch him
but I've named him Michael
and he quite likes drinking out of my Stanley
anyway I had a special mummy daughter
date day lined up with my youngest Olive
and I took her to Kiwi Valley Farm
which is in Waitakere
and I haven't been here for about five years
so I don't know what I was expecting
but it definitely exceeded my expectation
and honestly
this girl was having the time of her life
like she would come here every single day if I let her
we held the baby animals
and then we went around the farm
and she fed each and every single one
she was not gonna let one animal get away with not being fed
we went on a tractor ride
which was super fun
they took us up to the top of the farm
and you got quite a good view looking down
and there are few extra animals
and horses and things for her to look at
and then we went and lined up for a pony ride
and of course
we had to do it twice
she had to do everything on the farm twice
I'm not even joking
we were here all day
that was kind of the point
and I had nowhere else to be
and I was just happy she was happy
by the way if you're keeping tabs on the fairness scale like I am
and you noticed that I only took two out of
three children on a date this week
don't worry cause I took my eldest on a one on one date last week
anyway we wanted to round out the weekend
with some special time as a family
and the kids suggested going off to the movies
and I don't know about you
but I'm not a huge fan of actually going to the movies
and also I was thoroughly peopled-out
I looked at what was showing
and the only movie that we actually wanted
to go see was the new Willy Wonka
by the way this mess is why I normally don't do my skincare in my pjs
Anyway so I did a little googling
and it turns out
you can actually rent the Wonka movie from
the neon app here in Aotearoa
New Zealand and we collectively decided
aka I made the executive decision
that getting in my jammies
doing my skincare
having some takeaways
and watching the movie
from the comfort of my own home
sounded way better than going out
that is exactly what we ended up doing
even broke the rules and let the kids eat in front of the telly
which we never do
but don't worry
I did put a towel down
and I'm bloody pleased I did
because that pasta sauce was messy
And because I wanted the kids to feel like they were
getting a proper movie experience
and it was still a bit special
we ordered in some treats
which we never do
and can I just say that the Wonka movie was fantastic